Let me outline four different possible
explanations one can give and,
uh,
and I will just leave it,
leave it to the audience too,
to reflect on,
on these four possible explanations for
why we've had this extraordinary run of,
of,
of bubbles and busts over the last
number of decades.
A,
the first one,
which one might describe as sort of the,
uh,
the left wing or liberal answer is that
it has,
it has basically been driven by reckless
lending,
lack of regulation and greed and that,
uh,
and that in effect,
the entire boom since,
uh,
the early Reagan years in 1982 was
basically driven by,
um,
by,
by this escalating leverage that in
effect was more fake than rail.
And,
uh,
and that,
it is basically come to an end and that,
uh,
it worked well.
It did,
but it was basically the fault of the,
uh,
of the lenders and all kinds of agency
problems associated with them.
Um,
there's a,
there's a second type of political
events which is the right wing or
conservative answer,
which is that it basically was the fault
of the borrowers,
that they were recklessly borrowing all
this money and it was,
it was people who were too greedy and
buying houses and going on credit and
um,
and that it was sort of the product of a
narcissistic and selfish generation
that,
uh,
was not with short sighted and not
thinking about the future.
And under that sort of a narrative,
you might trace things back to say 19,
68 a and say that was the year that
everything went downhill in the u.
s and the hippies took over or
something,
something along those lines.
Now I think there's a,
it is,
of course,
the case of these two explanations are
not inconsistent and it is possible that
a,
there were problems with both the
lenders and the borrowers and that in
some sense,
a,
there was something about,
um,
uh,
something deeper about the whole
political system which have failed to
proactively deal with these things.
And just us speaking up,
speaking on my,
in my own context,
uh,
you know,
it was obvious that there was an insane
housing bubble three years ago and you
could talk about it,
you could scream about it,
you could go on CNBC and tell people,
uh,
there was a housing bubble,
they should not buy houses.
And it was like shouting into a
hurricane.
Nobody was willing to listen.
And,
uh,
and there is something about the,
um,
the nature of these things that is
extraordinarily a pro cyclical in a bad
way in terms of our political system
where,
when there is,
when everything's going well,
the regulations get loosened,
when things are going badly,
they get tightened.
So that in effect,
the political process has had the effect
of dampening these bubbles and booms,
but actually exacerbating them
tremendously.
And I think that is going to be one of
the real serious challenges we faced in
the years ahead in the technology
context.
For example,
in the late nineties,
uh,
which,
you know,
there were obviously tremendous.
We dealt with the abuses with Sarbanes
Oxley and there've been basically no
more.
I tech Ipos are virtually no tech Ipos
in six years.
So we had,
we had an excess of boom,
the regulators did nothing and then we
had an excess of Boston and we had an
overreaction and uh,
and again you can blame it on special
interest groups that are serving the
lenders.
You can blame it on,
on,
on the desire of the borrowers to keep
the easy money going,
but when basically a,
both of them and you have to wonder how,
how this,
how this can better be handled.
I think one of the challenges,
the,
uh,
that is happening on a global scale is
that the inability of our political
system to proactively deal with these
bubbles is calling into question the
very concept of democratic capitalism.
And I think one of the,
one of the challenges in the next,
uh,
next four to five years is that as sort
of a more authoritarian version of
capitalism,
of the sort that one sees in China will
get a lot more appeal.
Because the argument will be that it is
able to,
uh,
to resist the,
the appeal of,
of,
of people and special interests groups,
uh,
and sort of act on behalf of the whole
society.
And I think the challenge for the next
president is going to be to somehow,
um,
rehabilitate the good name of democratic
capitalism.
And,
uh,
it will be,
it'll be quite a big challenge.
And I certainly hope that whoever
becomes president will succeed at that.
Let me,
let me,
however,
outline a fourth,
a possible explanation for why so many
of these bubbles have turned into bus.
And this is probably my own,
my own personal hobby.
Hoarseness,
which is that there's not been enough
real growth in the economy and that in
some sense,
the reason so many of these booms didn't
work was that the whole economy was not
growing.
And this is not a question about finance
or politics or regulation or at least
not centrally about those,
but about science and technology and the
rate at which science and technology are
progressing.
And,
uh,
and I think sort of one,
and you know,
while there's incredible hype
surrounding tech companies and
scientific innovation,
the reality has simply not lived up to
the hype for a very long time.
And,
uh,
and the,
the,
you know,
the anecdote I would cite as if we were
sitting in this room in 1968 and talking
about what was the future of the US
going to look like in 40 years.
Uh,
you know,
we would have predicted the cation trips
to the moon.
I'm a space spaceships on Mars,
um,
massive increases in productivity.
Zerbe on triber,
a European writer wrote the American
challenge in 1967.
He said that by the year 2000,
the average person,
the US will be working seven hours a
day,
four days a week and have 13 weeks,
a year of paid vacation time.
Which,
uh,
which was a reflection of the incredible
growth in productivity that was set to
take place by accelerating technology
and science and I,
and it's gone.
Everything's gone the other way.
There's not been enough progress.
And I think,
I think the longterm challenge that I
would submit is that we somehow need to,
to get that restarted.
And it is very,
it's not easy.
Um,
it's,
it's broken down for a lot of very
complicated reasons,
but I think that,
that in some sense,
um,
that's the kind of thing that,
that needs to be very much restarted.
If I had a last thought on this is if
one had to look at the whole series of
bubbles,
the one that I think was the central
one,
perhaps not just in time,
but also in importance was the tech
bubble of the late nineties.
And in some sense when that one turned
out to go wrong,
it meant that none of them would work
because if there was not going to be
exponential progress in technology,
nothing else made sense and you could
leverage up in housing.
But eventually housing prices would go
down if there was no real growth in the
society taking place.
And the same.
I think it's true of a finance and to a
lesser extent of the,
uh,
the emerging market of the emerging
market story.
So I think the,
I would encourage us to very seriously
rethink why there's been so little
progress and how that can be
accelerated.
I think this is certainly one of the
great things that a big thing as an
impetus for doing.